Today's video is sponsored
by World of Warships.
What's it like
to have over a gallon
of hand sanitizer at once?
And what happens
if you heat it up
to the point of boiling?
Today, we're going to find out.
[Music]
Guys, most people only use hand
sanitizer in small quantities.
Fortunately, they sell
these refill packs
that are pretty big.
We want to see
what happens to hand sanitizer
if it heats up,
and not just a little bit at
a time, a lot of it at a time.
It does say on the bottle,
"Flammable. Keep away
from fire or flame."
We're not going to do that.
We're going to play
around with this.
We're going to try
a few different things with it.
And in the end,
I think we're going to end up
with over a gallon
of hand sanitizer
in this pot on a stove.
Here's the basic idea.
We have about a gallon
and a half of hand sanitizer.
We're going to put
that in a pot,
put that pot on the stove,
turn it on,
and see what happens.
So this is hand sanitizer.
It's usually used for killing
germs on your hand,
so you just need like
a little drop about that size.
It is way too cold
to be doing that.
Yeah, it does evaporate quickly.
There's actually steam...
There it is.
Coming off of that.
Now, I feel like I
have super powers.
So as it does that,
this is 63% ethyl alcohol,
and that kills the germs
on your hands.
And that's a really
good use for it.
But we're going to be using it
for some other stuff today,
because ethyl alcohol
is flammable.
Before we do the whole
gallon at once,
let's do a few
smaller scale things.
I want to see just
how flammable this is.
Flammable test.
[Music]
Ah.
Ah, yes.
[Music]
So it doesn't
burn super quickly,
it doesn't burn super hot,
and as you can see we're able
to leave it on her hands
for a few seconds without
causing any real problems.
We just burned off
some of the alcohol,
so it's now a higher percentage
of water and glycerin,
and less percent of alcohol.
[Music]
More.
Yes.
[Music]
You know those,
those happy birthday candles,
the trick candles
that keep relighting,
this is worse.
[Music]
Aha!
Now that the alcohol
has burned off,
this smells amazing.
It's kind of perfumey now,
like I knew some hand sanitizers
had perfumes in them.
This is about as
bland as you can get,
but I think we might
be smelling the what?
The aloe vera in it, maybe?
Well, we've played
with small amounts
of it at a time now,
I think we need more.
[Music]
Don't cross the streams.
Crossed.
Universe is broken now.
[Music]
Whoo.
That's chilly.
Now, it does look cool though.
It looks like my hand
is just like encased.
Wow.
Yeah, it looks like you,
you resin do your hand.
Yeah.
When things evaporate
off of our skin,
they take heat with them.
And if something
evaporates faster,
it's taking more heat away.
Alcohol will evaporate faster
than water will,
and so it will leave your skin
feeling cold very quickly.
Even more so, for instance,
acetone will do that.
Because acetone
evaporates even faster
than this diluted alcohol.
[Music]
All right, there's adding heat.
Cool.
And now we run.
That's over a gallon,
so it's going to take a while
before I think we see anything,
but I don't think it's a good
idea to be in here with that.
Just in case so...
We're gonna skedaddle,
and let the cameras
do their thing.
While we're waiting
for that to boil,
let's talk about our sponsor
for today's video,
World of Warships.
Guys, this game is freaking fun.
We've all downloaded it
onto our computers.
We kind of binge at it all morning.
I kicked his butt.
>> No. Maybe.
>> You guys should play it too.
The game is free to play.
It's a great balance
of action and strategy.
You've got a naval fleet
that you're commanding.
You're driving those
around fighting other people,
and they're all based on like
real iconic historical warships,
which is pretty cool.
As you play,
you unlock new ships.
You can just grow your fleet.
Start taking over,
dominate the Seven Seas.
The gameplay is pretty detailed.
One of the things I
think is the coolest
that weather will
affect the game.
If you've got wind
blowing towards you,
then it's harder to move
through the water.
Your maneuverability is changed.
Where your shots land is going
to move with the wind as well,
so you have to learn to take
those things into account.
It's not just point
and shoot like some games.
Gotcha!
New players can register
with the code:
PLAYWARSHIPS2018 to
receive 250 doubloons,
1 million credits,
the HMS Campbeltown
Premium Ship, one port slot,
and three days premium time.
Hit that link in the description
below to collect your own
special starter pack.
I'm kicking your butt, Nate.
I'm kicking your butt.
We're on the same team.
Wait, are you
actually shooting me?
Yeah, I was actively
shooting at you,
and now, I'm going
to fire missile at you.
Don't shoot me, and let me live.
Nah!
[Music]
It caught!
Yeah!
That sounded neat.
And you can still see...
Okay.
So now, with the fire,
it's boiled off all of the steam,
so you can just see like bubbling,
boiling gel inside that pot.
Yeah.
It's now shooting bits
of flame out of the pot.
The ground around
it is lighting.
This looks amazing.
Also, we're lighting multiple
things on fire right now.
And so far, at least,
the fire is sparse enough
that I'm not worried
about like the propane tank
heating up or anything.
No.
[Music]
But as it's boiling,
it is the fumes
that are actually catching fire.
The liquid itself isn't on fire.
You can see,
it's just kind of resting
on the top of the pot.
That's amazing.
Well, we succeeded in auto
igniting the hand sanitizer,
and nothing is spitting
out quite so far
as we thought it might,
so we feel pretty safe standing
where we are.
But now, we need to do
something with all of that.
You guys saw
how difficult it was
for us to blow out just
a small cup of this stuff.
It started steaming
really quickly,
and I think
that just so much heat
from the bottom was causing
the water in this to boil,
or the alcohol to boil.
Whatever was turning
into a vapor,
and that was raising up
through the rest of that gallon
plus of hand sanitizer.
We started seeing steam come up
with these cool
little like bubbly...
I don't know.
It looked like a special
effect of a swamp,
if the swamp were clear,
kind of thing.
Just because it's
so thick and viscous,
and then once it
really got going,
I especially like,
I noticed it because of
the sound first.
Because you just heard this...
There's like a cartoon
bubbling boiling noise.
What's that noise?
I think this point,
as Calli was saying,
it's time to do
something else with it.
So we're going to try
and turn off the burner,
carefully lift that pot
off using some tools,
set it down,
and then knock it over,
and hopefully, just
have like a flood
of burning alcohol spread
across the dirt.
I love my job.
Lifting.
Carrying.
It's still shooting
boiling alcohol.
Sat that down.
But it made it cool noise.
That's just going
to keep burning itself.
Let's turn off the stove.
[Music]
What is that noise?
I think it's bubbling.
Bubble, bubble,
toil and trouble.
[Music]
The world's most
dangerous game of hockey?
[Music]
Yes.
Wait...
No, no, put it out.
I didn't mean
for it to land like that.
You almost killed it.
[Music]
Oh, paint with fire.
We do say things.
That's a really cool color.
Like blue to purple to orange.
And the sparks.
The sparks that are coming
out of this is just...
Look at that.
That's beautiful.
Thanks again for today's
sponsor, World of Warships.
Hit that link in the description
below to collect
your own special starter pack.
Guys, that's not all.
You know, we've always
got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you'll never miss
out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.